my colleague Ben van Dijk and myself are
both data scientists at data science
comm and today we're going to give you
an introduction to customer lifetime
value modeling in Python but before we
start I would like to give you I would
like to say a few words about our
company data science comm at data
science on comm we have created and
end-to-end comprehensive platform to
provide data scientist with a
collaborative and scalable environment
that allows them to do their work more
efficiently so we led the data
scientists use the open-source tools
that you're familiar with
they love while allowing them to move
their work off their platform and into
production as quickly as possible so in
our platform your data science projects
are backed by your version control
provider of your choice whether it's
github gitlab or bitbucket and by a
scalable on cloud OMM infrastructure so
I would welcome all you guys to stop by
our booth to get a demo over platform
later on so to get back to customer
lifetime value this is a brief overview
of our presentation so we're going to
start by giving you a little bit of
background about CLV and why you should
care about customer lifetime value model
and then we will give you a quick
overview of the different CLV context
and it's important to understand the
definition of these different contexts
because they actually help you determine
what kind of models you need to model
your business setting and then we're
going to go into a deep dive of a
particular model the parental and DD
privilege SiC model this is a Bayesian
model and we're going to tell you why
you should be using this model and I'm
kind of what kind of insights you can
extract from this model and finally
we'll have a little lab where we
actually implement this model in a
Jupiter notebook using PI MC and so you
can actually follow the notebook at this
link here it's a public get up repo
that contains all of the information
about the model and how you can train it
on your data set so what is customer
lifetime value so customer life is
essentially just a total profit of the
entire relationship with the customer so
when you think about profit you think
about costs which are the cost that you
need that you take to have to take into
account when you want to attract service
and maintain a customer and then the
revenue part and the revenue is just
essentially the number of transactions
that a customer is going to make and the
value of each one of those transactions
in dollars and there's additional
component to that to that value that are
let's say harder to quantify like the
network effects or word-of-mouth effects
so customer can bring their friends into
your business and that's actually
extremely valuable in our in our
presentation we will focus exclusively
on the revenue part of this equation so
we will not address the cost part simply
because in general the revenue modeling
revenue is actually much more difficult
than the cost and so if you're familiar
with customer lifetime value literature
these are known as equity models and so
we can really summarize CLV by saying
that it's a metric that tried to capture
how healthy a relationship is between
the customer and a business
before we start doing into a lot of
details can I get a show of hands of who
is implemented CLE model before okay
it's good about 30 people that's great
so now why why would you care about CoV
well CLV is used in many different
purposes you can use customer lifetime
value to actually segment your customers
and find the most profitable ones you
can also identify the traits and the
features that are associated to these
very valuable customers and so you can
try to find more of these highly
valuable customers in the future and
it's really useful to be able to
determine how you can allocate your
resources among the different customers
that you have and it also gives you a
baseline for how much you should pay to
acquire these different customers so
let's start to discuss a little bit
about the business contexts that are
associated with CLV so the first
dimension that we're going to look at
the first one that's actually the most
important one in determining what kind
of TLB model you're going to use is
whether or not your business is in a
contractual versus a non contractual
setting in a contractual setting the
depth of a customer can be observed and
so this is your typical membership like
services where I someone does not renew
their membership then you know that they
have left your business and so these
these situations are often model using
survival based approaches and in the non
contractual setting which is the one
that's really common among online
retailers is the one in which the
customer that is actually unobserved and
so in this case the model will the
lifetime of a customer will be a latent
if you want unobserved parameter and so
typically in these models the customer
lifetime distribution is modeled via
exponential models
and so this is your Amazon of the world
and the second dimension that's really
useful to look into is that this screen
versus continuous purchase opportunity
in the discrete case the purchases can
only occur at very fixed frequencies so
you can imagine if you have a magazine
subscription again the magazine once a
month so that's one example of a
discrete purchase opportunity but a
continuous one is when the purchase can
happen and at any given time in the
relationship so if you look at it in a
table we actually included here
different business examples that fall
into each one of these four quadrants so
in the continuous purchase case in the
non-contractual setting this is your
online retailer really or movie rental
medical appointments hotel stays and the
contractual setting would continuous
purchases Costco is a good example
so Costco knows when you leave the
business because you don't renew their
membership but you can purchase at any
given time while you have that
membership and so discrete purchases in
a non contractual setting you have
prescription refills is a good one a
good example charity fund drives that
tend to happen at pick a fixed frequency
once a year for example event attendance
is not a good one and then in the
discrete purchase case where you have a
contractual setting then you have your
canonical magazine newspaper
subscription fitness clubs and a lot of
insurance policies also follow that
category so the CoV equation is very
simple it applies to all four quadrants
actually I should mention before we go
and talk about the model that we will be
focusing only on this quadrant in red
here in this presentation
this is typically one of the hardest
quadrant to model they've been mostly
probabilistic models I've been used to
model lifetime value for this particular
business setting and so it will
introduce the brand BD later in the
presentation but the C of the equation
is very simple it's really the total
number of purchases that each customer
is going to make times the value of each
one of these transaction
the customer level and so traditionally
these two parts of the model have been
attacked separately these are typically
two independent models and in our
presentation we'll really focus on
modeling the number of purchases the
total number of transaction that
customer is going to make and it's just
typically the hardest part to model and
so we're going to jump into an
introduction to the Pareto and BD model
how many of you have heard of this model
before okay but it doesn't that's good
and then this is a article Bayesian
model so I'm going to give you a brief
introduction to that model and how you
can train it on your dataset so before
talking about the model let's figure out
what kind of data you need to actually
train this model so this diagram
actually illustrate pretty well the kind
of data that you need so you need a
transactional data set so essentially a
log of each transaction that every
customer is making in your business and
so here in this diagram you have
different customers making transactions
at different times so these transactions
are represented by a vertical line and
the horizontal line shows time going
from left to right and so in many
businesses customer lifetime value is
modeled using very simple heuristics and
the classical example is just averaging
pass transactions that have happened and
inferring that people are going to make
the same number of purchases in the
future or in the same rate of purchases
in the future so if you look in this
particular case if you use that Urist ik
you would say that customer the first
customer actually is more valuable than
the second one because they've made more
transaction in the past or as this
customer here tends to make purchases
more that are more spaced in time and
actually customers would be here is more
likely to make purchases in the future
than this first customer who hasn't been
making any purchases in a long time
and so probabilistic models are very
good at capturing the ethereal genius
behavior among customers and so that's
why they're preferable than using simple
heuristics
so essentially that's what you need and
the goal is transactionally then the
goal of the CLE model here is to predict
what's going to happen in the future for
these customers
the Pareto and Beauty model uses
essentially two dimensions to
characterize the behavior of your
customers and these two parameters are
latent or unobserved parameters so the
model is actually going to be able to
constrain those the first one is the
purchase account if you want to purchase
rate that was use a number of purchases
in a given amount of time and it's
typically modeled or characterized by
the Greek letter lambda and the lifetime
which again is not observed directly in
this case is modeled with or represented
by the Greek letter mu here so really
the purpose of trade owned BD is to come
up with estimate of these two parameters
at the individual level so lambda mu so
the new so the lifetime is actually
going to be represented by an
exponential distribution and mu is the
slope of that exponential distribution
missus at the customer level so on top
of that so the CoV the permeability
model is a year article bayesian model
and the your article part of that model
comes from the fact that we're going to
use a prior distribution for each one of
these parameters lambda in view and this
prior distribution is going to be based
on our belief of how these parameters
are distributed in your customer
population your customer cohort so if
you have a customer that has made very
few purchases it's going to be hard for
you to constraint lambda mu very
accurately for that particular customer
but you'll be able to use your knowledge
of the customer population to really
infer that these values would be able to
use that to to constraint lambda a
little bit more so whereas if you have a
customer who has made a lot of purchases
then the likelihood function will
actually be driving the estimates of
lambda mu
and so to be a little bit more specific
the Pareto and BD model making
assumptions on how the drought that all
the purchases are distributed for each
customer
so the assumption here is that it
follows a Poisson process that the
purchases the time of the purchases are
somewhat random and that the life time
actually follows an exponential
distribution and in this particular
model the priors on both lambda and mu
follows gamma distributions so if you
were to derive the likelihood function
of that model you would realize that you
actually don't need all the transaction
information for every single customer
what you need are essentially three
quantities the first one is the recency
and the recency is just the time between
the initial purchase made by a customer
and their last purchase in a calibration
window of time so this is called the
recency and the frequency actually the
frequency here is a misnomer is the
repeat frequency is the number of
purchases that the customer has made
beyond first one so in this case this
customer has made a repeat frequency of
8 and the last parameter that you need
is the duration of your calibration
period so the duration of the time
period you're going to use to train your
model which is represented by capital T
here so these three parameters are are
known as the RFM data structure for
recency frequency and if you also
include monetary value which we're not
going to do in this presentation this is
where the M come from monetary value so
I think I'm going to let my colleague
Ben here show you how you can generate
an RF M object very easily and then
Jupiter notebook thanks Jer so in our
example notebook here if you scroll down
halfway or about a quarter of the way
you see I we the typical data set that
is used in a lot of the literature on
these models is the CD now data set does
anyone remember the company's CD now or
has ever purchased the CD okay a couple
pree Amazon I think Amazon acquired them
many years ago but this is a
transactional data set they sold CDs in
this case it's a continuous time
purchase you pattern you you can buy CDs
whenever you want and the transaction
log here kind of looks like this we have
a customer ID you have a date and you
have a quantity purchased and this is
basically what you need to start working
with these types of RFM models is so if
you have any kind of business where
you're selling something you probably
have what you need to start and here
what we're doing is there's a Python
library out there right now called
lifetimes which has been contributed by
Cameron Davidson puan who has actually
written quite a bit about probabilistic
programming using PMC and this is
another one of his projects and he
provides actually utility functions for
loading this data set you know for
constructing these benchmarks yourself
and then he provides utility functions
for creating the RFM data set and of
course it's easy to do on your own but
this is what it's going to look like
where we've specified the customer ID a
date when we want the training period to
end and then what frequency bucket we
want to group our transactions in and so
in this case we have we're doing some
kind of aggregation and you want to
select a frequency that won't obscure
too many purchases if someone purchases
every week and you select a frequency of
month what you're going to group all
those transactions within that month
into one observation so you want to
select appropriate granularity to your
data so that's creating the RFM object
that's all the data you need that's one
of the reasons these models are are
really attractive is they don't require
a particularly large quantity of data
and most most people who
you know operate this kind of business
have this this data readily available
thanks man so now let's talk a little
bit about the training process and so
for those of you who are already
familiar with machine learning model I
think that this slide will be pretty
intuitive here so what's going to happen
in practice is that we're going to
select a training period over which
you're going to train the model and
we've run a lot of simulations
internally and we we found that we at
least three times the typical inter
purchase time of your customers is the
kind of duration that you need to get a
good performance out of that model three
times really is the minimum we recommend
five to ten times is is definitely
better so you train your model over that
period of time and then what you want to
do is you want to validate your model
over a holdout period and again here we
recommend at least have the size of your
training period so here what we we
definitely want to avoid is a case where
you validate over a period of let's say
a couple of weeks when your customers
are making purchases every few months on
average so that holdout beard is going
to be pretty meaningless so you want to
make sure that your holdout there is a
is a size that's comparable to your
training period and so if you're
satisfied with the performance of the
model then what you want to do is you
want to take all of that data from both
the training and the validation period
and then forecast for period that could
depend on the company's need could be a
year a few years depending on the
forecast that your business actually
needs so now let's jump into the
training of the Preta and beaten model
because in this section of the notebook
we have some of the actual specification
of the model and you can find all this
in the link two papers that we've
referenced but I want to kind of show
the PMC implementation and see if there
are other implementations out there they
typically use the analytical
approximation and we think this is a
nice way to use Bayesian methods in
particular Markov chain Monte Carlo
methods because then we can approximate
the full posterior of the model
parameters and we can really gain a nice
understanding of the uncertainty around
our estimates not just say that the
average case so how many of you have
used PI MC or heard of it okay a few of
you
yes it's an excellent way to get started
if you're interested in building these
kind of hierarchical Bayesian models
which you really are really would be
very difficult to solve analytically
they're very easy to specify in this
language and which is which is just
Python and to to build and compute
things that would be really be
impossible otherwise so to start off
with what we have here is because our
likelihood function is not just an
off-the-shelf distribution we define our
kind of custom likelihood function and
in many cases you'll be fine with just
whatever distribution whatever
likelihood says no GLM you'll have
normal likelihood but in this case we
implement the likelihood function from
above as a custom continuous
distribution here and the two components
are we override the constructor with our
two parameters lambda mu and then we
implement this log P which represents
the log likelihood of the parameters
given the data and so these are our data
points we're going to follow the
notation in the literature so X is the
frequency t underscore X is the recency
and T is that length of the observation
period
okay so now let's get into the actual
model here you know we have mentioned
previously these are the parameters of
the prior distributions those so those
are the two gamma distributions so for
lambda the purchase rate we have R and
alpha and for mu the lifetime parameter
we have s and beta and we give these non
informative prior distributions and
there's an interesting paper about how
this half Koshi is convenient for that
and here we attach those priors to the
individual parameters and the the key
thing to note here is we've added this
shape argument we've specified that and
that is equal to the number of customers
in the data set so we have one lambda
parameter for every customer in the data
set and the same thing from you and then
here we reference that custom
distribution and then we start our
sampling here and after a while it
completes and then we get some
diagnostic plots here and then we've
also included a couple of functions that
allow you to compute the key quantities
of the model including the probability
that a customer is still alive i t
because these is a transaction model we
don't know for sure whether they're
going to come back or not so you can
calculate the probability they're still
alive at some point in the future
condition on their previous purchasing
behavior and then the cumulative
expected purchases in some future period
so how many more purchases are they
going to make with you so that's that's
obviously a really actionable one you
can use this to make predictions about
future purchases that's right
thank you Ben so
just to get back to some of the
actionable quantities you can get out of
this model so what Ben is show you is
how you can actually train the model and
extract the model parameters but you may
ask yourself so why do I go through this
exercise of finding all these model
parameters so why is this useful for my
business to train a model like this so
there are a number of actionable
quantities you can actually extract from
the model and as Ben mentioned one of
the most important one is the number of
future purchases that each one of your
customers are going to make so this is
one example here where you have a
customer who's made purchases in the
past we have trained the model between
the initial purchase and the time now
and what we're trying to do is to
forecast the number of purchases that
this customer is going to make over a
period of time DT and so we'll do this
process for each pair of lambda mu that
we get in our MCMC chain so we get a
vampeer of lambda mu for every single
customer and every chain and MCMC
sampler so what we trying to do is to
value the number of future purchases and
so you can think of it as being
essentially decomposed into two
expression which is the number of future
purchases given the customer level
latent parameters so these values of
lambda mu and the fact that the customer
is alive at capital P times the
probability of that customer to be alive
at t so this is represented here by
these expression where n is really what
we're looking for is the number of
purchases made in a given amount of time
DT in the future given your model
parameters and your observables so these
expressions actually these two
components on the right can be derived
analytically and I won't go into the
details it's pretty easy to derive
actually but these expressions are very
simple and you can evaluate these two
components for every single value of
lambda nu for every single value of the
chain or chain iteration number I should
say so let me just mention something
that the probability of being alive
actually is very useful if you are
trying to determine which of the
customers are
out to churn so it's a way to assess
that as well and so I think let's just
jump into the notebook a little bit and
take a look at those actionable insights
sure so in the last section of the
notebook in the model checking section
you know we can use this kind of
prediction function that we talked about
to do out-of-sample evaluation so we we
can use lifetimes also provide the
utility function for generating this
basically the RFM with an additional
calculation of what actually happened in
that holdout period here so let's take a
let's step through an example for a
single customer so we'll choose the
customer at the 150th index and so if we
look at their RFM record we see that in
the calibration period with this sub cow
they made two purchases and then the
most recent purchase occurred 17 weeks
after their first their first initial
purchase so that gives them a recency
and then we see that their frequency in
the next 39 weeks of our holdout period
ended up being 3 so they made to repeat
purchases in our observation period and
then 3 in the subsequent period so to
make a prediction for this customer we
take the we extract the posterior
distributions for lambda and mu from our
trace we get the entire 2000 data points
for that particular customer and then we
plug that in along with the 39 week
window for our holdout period into the
predict function and we can see for this
customer we ended up predicting they're
going to make one additional purchase so
how did we do we did ok they actually
made three purchases we predict one but
we did at least get that they were still
alive in this case so we were on target
there
so now that we've stepped through one
let's take a look at the entire customer
cohort we have here so I'm just wrote a
really kind of crude loop to loop
through the entire array of posterior
parameters and then I added that I took
the mean for each customer the posterior
mean predicted purchases and place that
back in the data frame under predicted
here and so how do we do there we
actually did pretty well so we observed
1788 repeat purchases in the holdout
period and we predicted 1724 so that's a
pretty good result in aggregate and you
can actually plot that this is a
standard diagnostic plot in a lot of the
papers on this topic we're going to look
at Bend by number of transactions in the
calibration period we plot the average
number of transactions in the holdout
period for observed and what the model
predicted and then the dotted line
represents a simple heuristic of well
we're just going to observe kind of
based on the previous rate and you can
see that the the model is able to do a
really good job of picking up the kind
of shape of purchasing and life time
here and most of the distribution most
of the action is actually in most
customers don't make any repeat
purchases and you know so the down here
is where most of the observations are
and the model does those really well out
here once you get out here in many of
these cases there might only be one or
two customers but even given that the
thickness of data in terms of number of
customers we've observed so much
behavior from them that we can actually
fit their purchase frequency very well
in this data set and then we can
calculate the RMS see across all the
individuals at about one point four
and then we have a bunch of links to
further reading on lifetime value here
and in general these are some great
books for more Bayesian methods I wanted
to point out also that our platform
customers designs are complex customers
have access to a customer lifetime value
library that Ben and I have been
developed over the years where you can
have a series of models that you can use
in different business contexts that we
we validated over the years so in
summary what we've learned today is what
clb models are and why they're useful
and also that there's really no one
one-size-fits-all here that CLV models
are really applicable in very specific
business context and that give you an
introduction to the Petaling BD model
how you can train the model and I can
extract actionable quantities from it
thank you
[Applause]
we have time for some Q&A I think so any
questions this
whether you would extend your model to
take into account more information about
the customers for instance like the
types of things that they're purchasing
or other features yes so the question is
about how we can incorporate additional
information such as customer features
yeah that's that's actually a great
question and one of the in one of the
references we linked to another proposed
model where instead of the two separate
Gama priors on the lifetime and purchase
rate parameters instead that's a
multivariate normal prior that then has
a linear regression component of that
that is that you can include those kind
of features so then out of that you can
derive based on the fit of the
regression you can get actionable
insights into what are the specific
attributes of the customer that drives
the results of those parameters the
estimates of the parameter in this case
the relationship between lambda the
purchasing great mu is a simple linear
regression model so you can extract
coefficients there and kind of gauge the
relative importance of each one of those
parameters so people think as lambda and
she'll be literature as the engagement
parameter and you as a loyalty Holloway
all the customers it's a measure of MU
in this case yeah have you thought about
two issues one is seasonality the other
is generate growth it has been hectic
for me so I was wondering yeah yeah
that's that's another really good
question and we've actually come across
this in our work so Steven ality and
just the general kind of growth
trajectory is definitely important
regarding seasonality one way to help
with that is to make sure in your
training period you observe a full
seasonal turn if that's not available
for whatever reasons you don't have the
data available or your company just
been around that long you know you could
take some other fit kind of a say a
time-series seasonal model on top of
this and then adjust your forecast using
that and that's also what I would
recommend for if there's any kind of
exogenous shock say you spend a bunch
more on marketing that might change you
know customer behavior in the future
which wouldn't be reflected in your
training period and again you could use
say a time series model to do an
adjustment on the predictions that are
generated by this model yeah they're
also partially using micro models that
have addressed that particular issue of
seasonality where the value of lambda
and you actually change it can change
over time so if you're in period of like
the holiday season for example what
you're purchasing rate on average is
going to go up then these models can
account for that and generally what we
have service that and the cases where
your customers make only a handful of
purchase or less it's very hard to
actually get that signal
there's models out there like the Pareto
GGG model which is a variant of this
model where actually it can allow for
the Poisson assumption here is it's kind
of lifted and then you can assumes
periodicity and the purchases so people
make purchases for example every week
every two weeks the Pareto DGG actually
can account for those for those patterns
I got two questions one was real quick
though you guys once you guys use gamma
prior is it just because it's a
conjugate yes okay that printer and BD
model is almost 30 years old
at this point I mean three add that it's
convenient for conjugacy and then the
second one is going back to the two
dimensions you mentioned for proving
contractual non-contractual and
continuous first non continuous what if
your business model is like a
combination to do for example if you're
running a game which is a monthly
subscription but you also have in that
purchases how would you model that
that's a great question so I think that
in this case you really are falling into
this
particular category where you're in a
contractual setting right and you can
make discrete purchases at any given
time right
continuous purchases sorry so this is
sort of in this particular setting here
and I don't want to go into too too much
details but we have a slide at the end
of our slide date you can access to
where we provide you with a series of
models for every single one of those
four quadrants so you can look at what
has been done in the past so I think
that you would fall into this particular
case here but there's a whole other
dimension to your problem that we
haven't talked in this presentation is
how do you assess monetary value because
customers will make transactions and
will make transactions with different
monetary value attached to them and so
in this case there are several models
out there and probably the most known
one of most well-known one is the gamma
gamma model we can talk about this later
if you're interested definitely any
other question
all right thank you guys thank you
[Applause]